[Music]
report is pretty strong it obviously
received pushback
from the chinese government incredible
pushback that delayed its release
yet it still really strongly confirms
what organizations like amnesty has been
saying and its findings are really
strong and really serious
[Music]
i had fully intended for it to be
released before the end of my mandate
and we're trying
well now we have received substantial
input from the government
that we will need to carefully review as
we do every time with any report with
any countries
[Music]
this report should be a wake-up call to
the international community as to the
reality of what is happening in xinjiang
there is now ample evidence that the
chinese government is committing grave
human rights abuses in xinjiang
including crimes under international law
[Music]
is
you